hey this is um I guess it's sort of
funny even though it's not I mean like I
I hate that I was right about this but
it has happened and I predicted it a
week and a half ago and it is happening
exactly loony Lindsey Graham or flimsy
Graham as some in the audience suggested
I refer to him has again flip-flopped
and now supports Donald Trump's absurd
erratic haphazard pullout from Syria
back on October 10th I did a story this
was just under two weeks ago about how
loony Lindsey had turned on Donald Trump
when it came to Syria flimsy Lindsey
tweeted pray for our Kurdish allies who
have been shamelessly abandoned by the
Trump administration this move ensures
the re-emergence of Isis and I told you
at the time you've got to be really
careful with flimsy Lindsey he is a
flip-flopper he is a put my finger to
the wind and see what will get me some
kind of attention type of guy he's
always been like this he will sometimes
come to conclusions that can sound
logical or remotely sane or not overtly
partisan but then the next day or the
next week he takes the exact opposite
position now as far as the Syria thing
is concerned I said 10 days ago let's be
careful Lindsey seems to be breaking
from the president here but he could
well be setting himself up to appear
impartial to appear unbiased when it
comes to Donald Trump's impeachment
which he opposes by the way and case in
point like clockwork now he is pleased
to be supporting Donald Trump's actions
when it comes to Syria he spoke to Trump
over the weekend and lo and behold
flimsy Lindsey came out of it saying
quote I am increasingly optimistic that
we can have some historic solutions in
Syria that have eluded us for years if
we play our cards right President Trump
is thinking outside the box the
president appreciates what the Kurds
have done certainly doesn't seem that
way he wants to make sure Isis does not
come back I expect we will continue to
partner with the Kurds in eastern Syria
to make sure Isis does
not real well well what a change of
heart for flimsy Lindsay this is the
Lindsey Graham routine if you think back
to the John McCain days when Lindsey
Graham would sometimes come out loudly
and say I stand with my good friend John
McCain and I am distancing from her
separating from taking a different
approach from what the Republican you
know talking point is and then it would
just change and then he would say well
okay no but I mean I stand with my party
in these toxic Democrats blah blah blah
this is Lindsey Graham's routine he can
be reasonable one day to guide us to
call out his side when they are wrong
but also to tell us when it is that they
are right and it will trick some people
and there are voters who eat it up there
are media outlets that fall for it
but then he'll just go back to the
brown-nosing and the normal stuff that
we actually have come to know Lindsey
Graham for and I told you about this
last week and it is happening exactly
someone emailed me saying David do you
think that it's possible that Lindsey
Graham is being blackmailed I don't know
about that there's no evidence of that
right now what we have evidence for is
that this has always been flimsy Lindsey
this is what flimsy Lindsey has done to
get attention he has always done it this
is the same Lindsey Graham who said a
couple of years ago Trump is a
race-baiting xenophobic religious bigot
that the Republican Party is doomed if
it elects Donald Trump and then he's
Trump's best friend and Trump is doing a
great job and he's more optimistic than
ever when it comes to what is going on
in Syria despite having said 12 days ago
that this is an abandonment of the Kurds
which it is which it absolutely is he's
a dangerous guy he's dangerous
because he is so attention-seeking in a
way that Donald Trump Trump's also
attention-seeking but in a different way
than Lindsey Graham that a lot of people
get fooled into thinking Lindsey is a
sort of post-partisan trustworthy guy
he's up for re-election in 2020
unfortunately no serious challenger
right now sadly Graham is polling last I
looked and there haven't been recent
polls because it seems so lopsided he
was polling at about 7:00
percent last I looked in his South
Carolina Senate re-election flimsy
Lindsey doing exactly what I predicted
exactly what he's been known to do for
what is it decades at this point make
sure you are following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
follow me while you're there at David
Pakman we will take a quick break and so
much more still to be discussed with you
today